today I'm going to talk about a topic
that comes up often in discussions
around systemic change and individual
personal responsibility I got an email
over the weekend and this is why I'm
even talking about this today the email
said hey David a Cuban American streamer
Destiny also known to summon our
audiences Stephen Kenneth Destiny
Bonnell II was recently interviewed and
Destiny said it's not hypocritical to on
the one hand say hey we need these
systemic changes but on the other hand
to encourage people to take
responsibility and give advice that
tells people individually how to best
solve their situation even if you're not
making the systemic change now I haven't
been able to find the clip doesn't even
really matter because this is a very
important topic and I want to talk about
it today because people have said to me
I get emails you know when we do uh
segments on the finance channel channel
or people will call in during live calls
with personal finance questions or
whatever the case may be people write to
me they'll say David how can you in good
conscience and in good faith advise
people about how to reduce their own tax
liability for example or work to reduce
your own but to advocate for higher
taxes for some people or another example
recently that came up I spoke about uh
funding a 529 College savings account or
educational savings account for my baby
daughter and people say how can you
participate in creating a 529 account
for your baby daughter while saying a
huge problem is that college education
is too expensive there are too many
student loans
the stock market is not accessible to
everyone maybe college education should
be less important I'm going to address
those specific questions but let's first
set this up properly
many people on the right
and even some on the left will argue
there's a hypocrisy to demanding
systemic change while encouraging people
to take responsibility for their own
lives and to do what is best for them in
the moment some will say and they say it
to me if you believe in the systemic
change then you should wait for the
government to fix the problem and not
bother trying to improve your situation
others might argue when you do what is
best for you it actually will delay the
systemic solution that you might be
calling for this is a very flawed and
sometimes absurd argument first of all
demanding a systemic change and
encouraging individual action are not
mutually exclusive in fact I would argue
they go hand in hand imagine we want to
see a more equal Society we would like
to see the government policy to reduce
inequality in society well we need to
demand policies that address systemic
inequality like a living wage and
affordable house in universal healthcare
and we should vote for candidates who
will do those things or who say they
will do those things but at the same
time
why wouldn't I encourage people to
educate themselves about how things are
today how things work today to improve
their skills to advocate for rights in
the marketplace to take advantage of the
tools that are available to them which
they might not even know about to
improve their lives today as we work to
elect officials who will make the bigger
systemic change secondly for me as a
progressive demanding systemic change is
not about giving up personal
responsibility it's about acknowledging
here's all the things I can do but there
is a superstructure a systemic reality
that is above and beyond what I can do
it doesn't mean I don't do the things I
can do it means I understand there's a
second layer to it some on the right
like to say listen you want health care
for all so that you David is a
self-employed person don't have to buy
your own health care that's that's what
I do right now
sure maybe but
I'm going to get myself health care
because I need health care it's not
really about whether I am getting Health
Care on the marketplace uh the
healthcare.gov while saying everybody
should get these are two different
things we're all products of our
environment and our choices are limited
by the opportunities and obstacles that
exist systemically but within that we
should still do what we can do to
improve our situation and if we want to
empower people to succeed we should
create a society that provides equal
opportunity when it comes to education
and health care and other economic
opportunities last thing encouraging
individual action also doesn't mean we
ignore the systemic inequality I I would
argue it's the opposite when I say to
people here are the actions you can take
I'm empowering them to do that and
better set themselves up to challenge
the status quo and to demand that change
when we encourage workers to organize
and demand better wages and working
conditions we're trying to improve their
lives but we're also trying to make a
systemic change that will benefit more
than just them now let's talk about some
of the specifics as they apply to me or
people that sometimes call in or
whatever the case may be I let's talk
about taxes I pay every dollar in taxes
that I'm legally required to pay at a
systemic level I think we need higher
top tax rates we should look at taxing
capital gains as income we should
eliminate the carried interest loophole
we should shift the tax burden away from
the poor all of these different things
at the individual level me David pakman
just sending more money to the IRS and
not taking deductions that are available
to me that's not policy that it's just
that's not the way we do it my policy
opinion is the one I just told you and I
vote for elected officials that would
put that in place for everyone at the
individual level I'm not going to pay
more tax than I'm legally required to
pay I'm not going to send money to the
IRS for no reason there is no double
standard the problem is an individual
taxpayers it's the systemic loopholes
and tax breaks
that let the wealthy incorporations
evade taxes the 529 account for my
daughter I'll do this one
if College costs keep going up as they
have been by the time my daughter is 18
the colleges I went to would cost over
two hundred thousand dollars a year
that's insane seems can't possibly
happen I spoke to Adam Schiff about this
the student loan industrial complex is a
mess maybe jobs should not require a
college degree and that'll put downward
pressure on the cost of college well
maybe maybe not
but what do I gain by denying my
daughter a 529 account that I can start
funding today I will advocate for change
and I will also do what I think gives me
the best insurance policy she doesn't go
to college or she doesn't need the money
from the 529 because we fixed the cost
of college or whatever in 18 years I can
change the beneficiary or take the money
out and pay the 10 penalty whatever
now to an advice example if someone came
to me and said I'm struggling I need to
make some more money or I want to make
more money am I going to rant to them
about income inequality tax loopholes
for the rich and that we should have
Universal basic income those are
systemic ideas I would tell them have
you looked at a side business is there a
certificate you can get to earn more
money at your current job is your resume
updated is there a skill you can
monetize there is not a hypocrisy or
double standard between advocating for
systemic change and in the meantime
advising people to do what is best for
their families when people we have a
caller who called in and said
I have a transfer my partner is trans or
my daughter is trans
um
I live in a deep red State it's getting
really ugly they're passing all this
legislation systemically we should work
in every state to protect trans people
at the individual level I said to them
you've got to decide for yourself do you
need to move to a different state if
you're able to
in order to do what you think is best
for your family right now sure in 20
years we might effectively protect trans
people in whatever state it was they
were calling from but in the immediate
if your family is in danger well how I'm
going to say it's no you've got to stay
there and of course not okay not a
double standard let's understand the
difference between the systemic and
structural and the individual